spektakulärer unfall auf der landstraße
131 zwischen elsdorf und appendorf im
kreis rotenburg in niedersachsen
sonntagabend verunglückte hier ein
milchlaster warum es passiert ist wissen
wir noch nicht sein fahrzeug kam nach
rechts von der fahrbahn ab und prallte
auf einer strecke von ungefähr 150
metern gegen drei straßenbäume und
schleuderte das schwere fahrzeug wieder
zurück auf die fahrbahn und kippte dort
um ein entgegenkommen da 41 jähriger
fahrer eines opel versuchte den
zusammenstoß mit dem liegenden fahrzeug
zu vermeiden bremste und konnte aber
diesen zusammenstoß
dem konnte nicht ausweichen der
autofahrer wurde schwer verletzt
der 33 jahre alte lkw-fahrer konnte aus
seiner zugmaschine in zwei meter höhe
klettern
auch er kam schwer verletzt in ein
krankenhaus
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren